Holly weird squares I'm not going to
make you wait for it I'm going to put on
my announcing voice and go right to wow
your favorite
favorite de Robin
and it's a holly weird squares Christmas
it's the best time of the year
let me tell you about our contestants
these are two Brave military guys so I
want everyone to give him a big round of
applause you know I love it first of all
thank you
we're playing for the X's is Mike from
Texas uh Mike from Texas is a petty
officer in the Navy he's been awarded
the Combat Action ribbon the joint
service Achievement medal and the Navy
Commendation Medal
you are a real man my friend aren't you
say good morning hey good morning
everybody uh I don't know about a man
but I'm just honored to be here
appreciate you listen to this
Mike is so good looking
that he's been called the most catfished
man in the military in other words
people use your picture to catfish uh
other people catfish women over 500 yeah
over 500 fake dating accounts have used
his photos to score chicks a woman once
paid a fake mic fifteen thousand dollars
to help him return from a deployment
this must be upsetting to you that
people are using your picture it
absolutely is and uh yeah it's gotten to
the point now
um that I still get messages about it so
I've gotten to the point I don't message
with anybody unless it's like a
dangerous situation like about a month
ago a woman said her friend was going to
meet up with a catfish profile and
that's pretty much the only time I'll
get involved anymore so uh yeah it's
kind of get no there's no medal for this
I wish there were though yeah let's get
right down to our game and meet our
second man who is another real man I'm
surrounded by real men playing for the
O's is Sean from Arizona welcome Sean on
listen to this guy's credentials Sean is
a former Army Green Beret by the way
Sean can can the Green Berets kick the
Navy Seal's ass I mean who is a better
uh undoubtedly undoubtedly really
yeah Navy Seals are often better looking
you know but uh
you're a good looking guy and and uh by
the way there is a rivalry right uh
really the things changed when they went
to or when Afghanistan and Iraq kicked
off and suddenly these swimmers thought
they should go to the desert doesn't
make a lot of sense to me
they're out of place right
what the [ __ ] are they doing out there
in those shorts you know both these guys
are real men but can either of them do
long-form improvisational comedy
thank you
foreign